My parents come from Bangladesh and both
of them are Muslims and we were raised
somewhat informally in that tradition,
uh,
for a variety of reasons.
A,
I say informal.
I mean we weren't observant in the sense
of going to some kind of religious
service on a very regular basis,
although certainly identified with in
this Broadway.
And I remember praying pretty regularly.
There are Ssris and you're supposed to
memorize them.
And I remember I was taking Arabic
lessons very briefly for maybe only a
couple of weeks and that I had an
argument with a tutor,
uh,
about whether androids have souls.
I remember,
uh,
I didn't feel as though it was getting
very satisfactory answer regarding the
androids having souls question.
So I kind of shirked my duties in that
regard.
And then,
um,
I suppose had a kind of broad interest
in religion as a phenomenon and I think
that I identify with Muslim communities
in some broad sense,
but I'm not all that reflective about
religion per se.
I kind of recoiled against people who
sneer at religion,
uh,
in part because I have a lot of friends
who are devoutly religious and relatives
and what have you.
At the same time I think that there is
such a thing as a religious impulse
that's some people possess or don't
possess and I think that I have far more
possessed the spaceman who's kind of
visiting Earth,
uh,
impulse rather than the religious
impulse.
Um,
although I also have a kind of booster
richness that I think that some
religious people have,
but it happens not to apply to religion
per se.
So that's not necessarily a very good
answer to your question,
but that is my,
those are my kind of broad impressions
of religion.
Well,
I remember once I'm overhearing a
conversation in which a guy was asked,
where are you from?
And he said,
New Orleans.
And then the interlocutors proceeded
ask,
Oh,
what was that like?
And he said something to the effect of,
well,
what do you think?
It was like all of these people saying
y'all all the time.
He had this contempt for it and that
really turned my stomach.
I just recoiled against it and I thought
to myself,
if you have objections to where you're
from,
you share them with your friends who are
also from New Orleans.
You don't share them with outsiders and
you certainly don't express that kind of
contempt.
It just seemed really untoward.
And then some years later,
as you may recall,
Hurricane Katrina hit New Orleans and
the same guy,
um,
uh,
he proceeded to write a kind of moving,
you know,
pieces about the devastation of his
native city.
And I thought to myself,
this person that's beneath contempt.
And,
uh,
I just,
at a very,
very basic gut level thing that,
uh,
this is just not a morally praiseworthy
individual.
And so I guess I think that,
um,
when you're engaged with something,
you should work to improve it to the
extent possible,
be constructive.
Don't allow your booster parishionist to
blind you to the kind of various foibles
and downsides of whatever it is that you
were associated with,
but do your best.
Act in good faith.
And you consider yourself kind of a
steward of this tradition that you're a
part of.
Whether voluntarily or involuntarily,
and in a way that's a little unfair
because shelby steele talks about the
totalitarianism of black identity,
the idea that no one is obligated to
identify with a certain thing and there
is a way in which I can see how that's
problematic and you know,
maybe if we could all be Rafe,
like beings who are free of those
associations,
that would be nice.
But that doesn't strike me as the world
and you know,
you're embedded in the context and being
respectful of that strikes me as
reasonable.